What do you think intento might mean?
Quiero is I want, and this o is showing that it's I.
If you heard intento, what do you think it might mean?
Try?
Yeah.
How did you know that?
Well Do you know how you knew that?
Well yeah, I sort of went from in intent
I intend to do something.
There's no rule here to convert intention to a verb.
It's not Asian, so we can't take off the Asian and put R.
Yeah
But we have intention, we know what is the meaning, so we can come a we can hear a verb like this and understand what it means.
Intento means I try or I'm trying.
I try or I'm trying
So how would you say I'm trying to publish it?
Again, it's something you think I can't say this in Spanish
Intento public uh publicarlo.
Good.
Intento publicarlo.
I try to publish it or I'm trying to publish it.
We've got both there.
Good.
How would you say I'm trying to administrate it?
Intento administrarlo.
Good.
Intento administrarlo
I'm trying to imitate it or I'm trying to imitate him.
Could mean either.
Intento.
Okay, it's it's imitation.
Exactly.
Imit
Now page in Spanish are completely silent.
You must be careful not even
to think them because they will have a habit of of slipping out even if you think it.
So it's written the H is written in convertible words for example, like hospital ends in A L
But it's not pronounced.
You must imagine that it begins with an O.
So how would you say hospital?
Hospital.
See you you thought of the H and the little kind of uh aspiration
came there which is fine but to get the perfect accent you really want to think in your mind that it begins with oh hospital there you are perfect hospital horrible
Good, and here we have an example of double R inside the word horrible.
If you can't pronounce that, you just make horrible and uh it will be perfectly understood.
There's no problem there.
Good.
How would you say habitual?
Habitual.
Habitually.
Habitualmente.
The word for now in Spanish is ahora.
Ahora.
This is spelled AH.
O R A.
A-H-O-R-A.
Aura.
Good.
Is the H silent in every uh Yeah, unless it's C-H, in which case it's like English, Ch
Ahora is actually the combination of two words.
A, which means to, and ora, which means hour.
So it's something like to the hour.
So that gives us another couple of words this way.
A meaning to in the sense of direction, to somewhere, and ora meaning our.
Ahora now
So, how would you say I want to cancel it, but I don't want to cancel it now.
We said that the word for ba is pero.
So we want to divide it up piece by piece.
I want
Quiero to cancel it.
Cancelar lo good.
But pero I don't want
No quiero to cancel it cancelarlo now ahora
So a big sentence which we might imagine that we can't take on if we divide it up bit by bit we realise that we can think our way through it.
The word for I go or I'm going in Spanish is boy.
Boy.
Good.
Now this is actually spelled V-O-Y.
Now the V in Spanish can sound like a V in English, like a V, or it can sound like a soft B, like boy.
You might be familiar with the word vamos
Which means let's go.
Literally we're going used a lot like let's go, bamos.
Now this is spelled V-A-M-O-S.
And what you probably hear there is a B
It really depends where you are.
In the southern Kaon around Argentina and Chile you hear a lot more V kind of pronunciation in many places.
Generally in the Spanish-speaking world it's like a soft B.
So we want to make that association now between V and soft B.
To remember this word, voy, we can think of voyage.
So we can see the connection there between voyage and to go.
I go or I'm going?
Voy.
I'm going now
Voy ahora.
Boyahora.
I'm not going now.
No voyaura.
Good.
No boyora.
How do you think you might say visit in Spanish?
Visit that?
Yeah, why did you think that?
Was it just a guess?
Well it's visitation visitation, does that exist?
I think so.
Visitation rights.
Exactly.
Very good.
This is it.
It's a word that exists that we only use uh in some contexts, like visitation rights.
Visitar, visitar.
If you're not comfortable with the soft P, just pronounce a V.
It doesn't matter.
When you practice Spanish, you're gonna pick up the accent of who you're speaking to.
So it's not a fundamental issue of ours right now.
So visitar.
I want to visit him.
Quiero visitarlo.
Good.
We can look at some other words now with this V sound and experiment a little bit with the sound.
So how do you think you would say visible in Spanish?
Visible?
Good.
Well there's something very good you're doing here.
If you're not pronouncing that S as a Z, like in English, visible
Many people at home will find themselves uh doing this, putting that Z there from English and pronouncing visible.
We don't want that, we want visible.
And the V is like a soft B
If you want more elaboration on what is this soft B, you can put a small piece of paper in front of your mouth and make the B in English like bucket and you will see that paper move with that burst of air that comes with bucket
That hard B in English is a plosive sound.
It means you gather up a little bit of air and you and you shoot it out when you make that B.
Where this B doesn't have that.
It's a soft one.
So you can experiment with that.
Again, like I say, we don't want to stress out about sounds.
To use a V sound is perfectly fine.
Viral.
Viral viral good so if viral is viral, how do you think uh virus might be?
Viral virus it's actually the same word uh uh you're just pronouncing it exactly as it is virus
Convenient Conveniente Conveniente Good